that's the opposition for sonny gray
whose last five have been dynamite you
know he is the kind of competitor that
you love to play behind
he brings an intensity
and a drive really kind of a bulldog
attitude
a fly ball to ground ball
and now gray contends with trey turner
popped up
jonathan indian
a one two three first for sonny gray
time for the indeed player resume max
scherzer in cincinnati three prior
starts he's three and oh with an era you
can barely see
the ballpark hasn't bothered him great
american small park you see the home
runs allowed down there zero
mad max here in this ballpark probably
gets a lot of ground balls and of course
gets a lot of swings and misses
facing india 270 batter
and this ball is drilled to left field
on the way back after it is gavin lux it
will make the catch
three thousand three career strikeouts
for max jersey he shakes and then agrees
and the payoff
three thousand four career strikeouts
with a breaking ball sonny gray takes
the hill he'll face max muncie to start
things off here in the second inning
swing and a miss struck him out
chris taylor in a one for 24 rut he
strikes out a lot
the shields
three up three down again for sonny
graham
well here's scherzer
a highly dangerous hitter over his last
52. scherzer's over 52
this year hasn't reached base in 56
played appearances that's the longest
streak in major league history to start
a year
over gray
india on the backhand off balance throw
is there in time
stolen base trey turner two down
that's trying to get him home
down on strikes muncie caught watching
this time gray's third strikeout of the
afternoon
the dodgers strand a runner at
second
now tucker barnhart sures are ready to
deal the payoff
and here it comes
got him swinging
strikeout number six for scherzer
scherzer now has gone 33 and two-thirds
innings without allowing an earned run
second man the dodgers have had at
second base today
now chris taylor hoping to get going
over his last 16.
and he hits one on the ground third base
side mustache boots it picks it up
throws to first he throws it away
and turner will head to third into
second
is taylor
and the dodgers have set up shop second
and third nobody out
gavin lux a chance to get the dodgers on
the board
this one bang in the right field that's
going down the line
turner scores taylor around third he
will score rounding second and on his
way to third as lux
two-nothing dodgers
gavin lux's right forearm feeling better
after the battle with the pitching
machine that hit him yesterday he
couldn't be in there now the dodgers
benefit from
his quick healing abilities to
get a couple rbis
and a triple
[Applause]
down the right field line and he was
thinking three all the way infield will
be in for cincinnati
as austin barnes looks to get luxol
and barnes hits a ground ball
lux is going to score on it
so a very productive out for austin
barnes three-nothing dodgers
an rbi groundout
22nd run driven in by austin
chris taylor happens to now be one for
two this afternoon following the scoring
change in the fifth inning
and a bun here comes trey turner to
score and sonny gray
thought about coming home and realized
he had no chance
safety screws and the dodgers now
leading
well trey turner's wheels
they are not they don't need to
suicide squeeze so he took his secondary
lead about two and a half steps
and then as soon as he sees the ball hit
the ground he is off and running
not a lot of runners with this firm a
bun
would get home but trey turner gets home
easily
tucker barnhart with two out of nobody
on
trade turner
being called off by mookie
three fly balls for max scherzer as he
wraps up the seventh inning of work
roger's up four nothing
it'll be gavin lux in this ninth inning
against garrett
garrett bang bang play and he beats
gavin lux to the bag
he doesn't go right away see that little
bit of a delay and gavin lux can run
so can amir
mookie is without a hit today oh for
four and two strikeouts
amir guerra is set to throw
[Music]
and
[Applause]
extends his hitting street to 10 games
and picks up rbi number 54.
mookie hammers it down into the corner
but the thing he's got to remember is
albert's in front of him and albert's
probably going to move up 90 feet mookie
with a big turret first and was like oh
yeah i gotta watch out
[Applause]
kyle farber is due up here's another
base hit today
tap to short seeger
[Applause]
lost it first base former safe
scores
5-1
two men on two out
all kindly needs is to get one out but
the tying run is on deck so it's a safe
situation
start three ball game
jason punches him out and the dodgers
win it 5-1 max scherzer's 15th win